tiempo atrás en clases de álgebra
aprendimos a factorizar cosas como x
cuadrada menos cuadrada y vimos que esto
es la diferencia de cuadrados que puedes
factorizar lo como x + x x menos sólo
para refrescarlo y puedes multiplicarlos
y verificar que obtendrás x cuadrada
menos de cuadrada pero bueno vamos a
hacerlo por diversión
esto es x por x es igual x cuadrada
luego x x menor y es igual a menos x
luego x x re positivo es igual a xe y
jeff por menos y es igual a menos de
cuadrado se cancelan y nos queda justo
el resultado
y lo que quiero abordar en este vídeo es
algo que no sabíamos cómo factorizar
antes y esto es la suma de cuadrados
así que si factor izamos xy bueno voy a
poner todo esto con un color un poco más
brillante si quisiéramos tratar de
factorizar x cuadrada este color rosa x
cuadrada más que cuadrada antes nosotros
sabíamos de números imaginarios números
complejos pero no sabíamos cómo
factorizar eso pero ahora vamos a
hacerlo y me gustaría tratar de hacerlo
y alentar a que en el vídeo próximo lo
hagas antes que yo tratando de expresar
esto con una diferencia de cuadrados y
usando la unidad imaginaria así que
tratemos de hacer esto entonces lo
primero que teníamos con las diferencias
de cuadrados era x cuadrada así que lo
dejamos por aquí la x cuadrada pero
ahora quiero escribir esta parte
esta parte segunda como restándole a x
cuadrada algo entonces nosotros vamos a
querer restar esto entonces podemos
escribirlo como de esta forma sería x
cuadrada menos por menos de cuadrada la
ye cuadrada negativa por un menos es
como si estuviéramos sumando como si
tuviéramos el positivo y por aquí
podemos poner este menos 1 que sería lo
que estaría multiplicando la ye cuadrada
ahora como nos ayuda a esto bien pues
esto es como está restando con el menos
1 pero para escribir esto como y
cuadrada
ya sabemos que por definición menos 1 es
igual a cuadrada o y cuadrada igual a
menos 1 así que escribamos lo de esta
forma esto sería igual a x cuadrada
menos y tenemos que el menos 1 es igual
a cuadrada entonces esto sería cuadrada
de cuadrada y ahora esto es interesante
y creo que puedes ir viendo para dónde
va esto pero bueno esto lo hace un poco
más explícito entonces ahora esto es x
cuadrado
menos menos
y estos dos podemos llevar ambos al
cuadrado entonces ya menos y por qué y
ambos al cuadrado y con estos usando la
y estamos listos para escribir esta suma
de cuadrados como una diferencia de
cuadrados y ahora podemos factorizar y
sólo de la misma forma que factor izamos
esta expresión original entonces esto va
a ser igual a x más esto de aquí que
sería y
x más y por equis
por x menos
y yo
x menos y podemos verificar que si
multiplicamos estas expresiones vamos a
obtener x cuadrada más cuadrada y
hagámoslo entonces tenemos x x x esto es
igual a x cuadrada
y luego tenemos x x y por menos y lo
cual sería y x menos y x de y luego
tenemos más y jr por x lo cual sería más
y equis y finalmente tenemos y por menos
y jeff lo cual sería menos y al cuadrado
sería menos y cuadrada de cuadrada ahora
estos dos términos se cancelan y luego
recordando que menos y cuadrada es igual
que y cuadrado es igual a menos uno y
luego este por este menos por este menos
del menos uno es como tener algo
positivo y finalmente nos queda x
cuadrada massieu cuadrada así que espero
que esto te dé una apreciación de usar
la unidad imaginaria como de hecho
podemos factorizar esta expresión es
esencialmente el producto de dos números
complejos y finalmente tú lo puedes
utilizar para algunas otras operaciones
esta factorización nos da